good morning millennials welcome back to
the toast stand ugh you know what I'm
really struggling Jax because it's the
final one no well yes
yes why are you struggling
so
it's such a layered story well good
thing for us that we have all the time
in the world that you love to tell
stories and you love layers
I do thank you so much for saying what I
could not say
I want to give it my all you know as you
mentioned today is our last show before
your very short maternity leave
and
I was ready last night I'm like oh I'm
gonna give these people an episode
they'll never [__] it forget
and I have had such a morning
that all I want to do is like be
negative Queen like you know
okay tell me about your morning and I'll
tell you if the negativity is warranted
okay it's not even a warranty like I
couldn't change it if I wanted to it's
my physical being now with negativity
you know yeah but the toast has a way of
turning a negative into a positive we
also can turn a positive into a negative
it just depends just give us enough time
so tell me what's alanium
so Ben golfed this morning
he I think he did like nine holes at
like the crack of dawn so he could do it
before work he's home already like
whatever but that meant he woke up at 4
30.
and he had the craziest loudest scariest
alarm
and I've been up ever since was it a new
oh the one
the one it's funny how we all actually
have the same alarms that's like kind of
the great equalizer we all have like the
same four to choose from
now I appreciate you trying to put a
positive spin on this listen so you've
been up since 4 30. it happened and and
let me tell you what I'm feeling
anger of course like how my husband
could be so thoughtless
so reckless
so dismissive you know
I'm feeling tired I'm not gonna lie I'm
talking very slow it's not it's very not
like me
and I'm feeling sad because all the
plans I had you know to be like this
kind of extraordinary podcast host today
I just it's not it's not feeling like a
possibility
anything is possible don't give up but
we're gonna work through this what now
it goes without saying what did you do
since 4 30 a.m I'd be happy to tell you
now it goes without saying I know you're
a mom you have 4 30 mornings every day
you know my battle and your battle my
journey and your journey are not the
same so let's just keep that out of it
okay yeah I mean I thought about
contributing how my night went you know
which it didn't go according to plan
either
it never does but I don't want to take
away from your negative experience
thank you I don't want to minimize what
you went through
so I laid for about an hour
till 5 30.
then I went on my phone 5 30 to 6.
posted some stuff on Instagram which
kind of alerted you know my my inner
circle that I was awake
my friend Abe called me he had just got
back got back from La so he must be like
off-kilter in terms of his timing as
well
and he was also just laying in bed mad
we just two people stewing in bed
and then I was like you know what should
we get breakfast
because I was thinking like why did I
turn this negative into a positive
and I was fully prepared to do that like
I was
tired but I didn't feel like terrible
so I went and met him for breakfast and
then as we're sitting there my friend
Margo text me she's like hey I'm up too
I'm like oh my God come meet us for
breakfast it's actually like a very nice
it was kind of like an episode of
Seinfeld just like a bunch of
girlfriends and Abe sitting at a diner
you know it was nice and I was ready to
kind of like
conquer make this my day make today my
[__] and I'm sitting I'm eating my eggs
I ordered something healthy I'm like
feeling good and proud of myself
and I just get hit
you know like the the wave of exhaustion
that's like nausea
I am familiar
so I was like guys I can't like I just
was broken at this Diner
so I walked I tried to like you know get
myself out of it keep trying to be
positive because we ate like you know up
really Uptown I was gonna walk home I'm
like I'll get my blood flowing after 10
blocks I was like girl I gotta get out
of here I held a cab actually ran into
some toasters on Lexington Avenue
um and then I got into a cab went home
and I've just been laying like a piece
of [__] in my bed ever since
until we had to start recording and my
spirit has just kind of diminished my
will to live has certainly diminished as
has my joy devive
and now we're here do you have a coffee
I had a Diet Coke doesn't count
yeah but I'm banking on a nap so like
the coffee will have to wait if you're
that tired you'll fall asleep
the coffee will have to wait
okay
I just I'm not feeling like you're
feeling mad for me
I do because you know the the what's
what's hard for you is still hard for
you even though it's oh my oh my God not
the craziest thing
um
I just I want to move on from it you
know
wow
wow okay like you've shared your truth
we all we stand with you against Ben as
we always do yeah like
this is Major like I'm definitely
thinking about contacting a lawyer like
that's how mad I am like I'm gonna Sue
how why did he do that like why didn't
he put on a delicate alarm
sleep on the couch so he's called before
and woken up early and he always like
disturbs me but never to the point that
it like fully wakes me up today was like
another level of carelessness and I
think we've learned a lot you know from
this experience as a family if you want
to golf in the morning you have to sleep
on the couch yeah or maybe I mean you
didn't fall back asleep were you hungry
no hmm
it happens
and I'm not really looking for like any
sort of reasoning to put the blame on me
like oh you woke up because you were
hungry no no just I'm just always trying
to find learnings for the next time
yeah my learning is couch yeah my
learning is
I'm like I'm about to start ruling this
house with an iron fist when it comes to
golf like we've taken this way too far
that's insane that he would choose to
wake up at 4 30 to do something like
yeah what is more pleasant than an extra
five hours of sleep
no if somebody was like you can meet
Taylor Swift but it's at five in the
morning I'd be like well tell her I say
hello
send my regards yeah yeah that's what's
really crazy like the golf Obsession has
gotten out of control
I agree like this is really kind of uh
and we're going into the weekend like
golf on the weekend
literally golf on the weekend golf on
the weekend no what were you singing
Love on the weekend but I made it as I
was thinking too yeah yeah but it didn't
sound like I made it my own
golf on the weekend it is hard yeah like
what's the next line it's like the same
thing love on the weekend why don't I
know how that song goes it's like love
on the weekend love love on the weekend
so now you understand my struggle so we
made it our own yeah so yeah I
understand your struggle but I don't
think you understand mine I do
understand yours because I've literally
been in a place where I've woken up at 4
30 and then had to stay up like till
it was just tactical time and then you
do hit a wall and crash and that happens
to be the time that we're recording yeah
I am definitely like not letting this
Mar the final episode like I will I will
persevere I will be strong because I'm
an incredibly strong person and and I
know nobody you know who's currently on
Earth has ever dealt with something as
difficult as what I'm dealing with
currently like I fully understand that
and like I know you don't have to say it
like I am a hero so
uh I like I feel hungover I I'm mad I
did have like two sips of wine last
night do you think that's what's going
on
you had two sips like literally two subs
nah
you don't think where'd you go to dinner
amaranth oh you guys love I figured you
went somewhere like
neighborhoodly yeah I went to
um dinner with uh two of my friends from
high school and their husbands and I
like brought them to one of my favorite
restaurants and like it was you know
when restaurants are just having an off
night like everything in the kitchen is
rotten and it just wasn't good I guess
yeah it just it was not it was bad and I
was like I brought shame to my household
I'm like oh me and Ben love this place
and they met her disgusting no like me
and Ben have no taste it was humiliating
I'm sorry so it's just lost after loss
for turdy Lou it is but again final
episode before your break I'm like
that's so dramatic like there'll be
patreon episodes like there'll be plenty
of content you guys will be hearing from
us but not the traditional toast and you
know what I can't lie like it does feel
good
like the way people are like losing
their minds they're like you should have
given us more warning like as if we
could have planned anything about
Jackie's pregnancy but I digress the way
people are so mad like I've never felt
more loved and relevant in my life I
know it's nice to be missed
it is you know what I need I think we
need to like the one thing our show was
missing there's just one thing yeah
it's mystery because we're just like
always sharing everything it's so true
and maybe after this month we'll kind of
be like those like mysterious girls like
those podcasters yeah they're so
mysterious we'll be like mystery Dow
Jones
literally yeah I agree we need to inject
some mystery into the Pod so after today
we'll see you on the patreon where you
can uncover the Mysteries yeah but you
know by the way jaggy we could be
unmysterious for a price oh for sure
wait also now that it's like the final
episode before your leave how are you
feeling like can we get like a little
pregnancy update oh I'm feeling good I
mean pregnancy wise physical wise like I
am broken especially like towards as the
day goes on like I just break down by
the night I just can't stop like
groaning and complaining I'm just like
oh and every I'm always like and Zach's
like what what I'm like it just is he's
like grabbing the hospital bag yeah he's
like what was that I'm like just life
right just everything existence was it
was it a kick I'm like no the kicks
don't hurt like it's everything else
like it's right breaking my back
Streisand is the only one who
understands what I believe that and it's
just it's really getting physically
very painful and uncomfortable
uncomfortable is really the word like
I'm very uncomfortable right now in the
mornings I feel good because I get like
to sleep I'm off my feet for however
many hours and I wake up feeling
refreshed but as the day goes on I just
really deteriorate and it's it's really
increased in intensity can I ask you a
question that might be personal and you
can just like say no I'm not answering
oh sure so something I've noticed just
like being at your house and like being
on FaceTime with you all the time is
that you have foregone bras
no and uh so I wear I wear like a hatch
the hatch maternity bras which are for
pregnancy and nursing
um and that's what I wear around my
house all day most of the time this
morning I didn't put a bra on yet but
when you come over I'm always wearing
like it's a very very loose bra so it
doesn't dig in at all it doesn't provide
a ton of support but it's more than
nothing
got it because I would imagine like for
girls like us like not wearing a bra is
like crazy no the digging in is worse
than God than the sagging than like
carrying your boobs yeah um and you just
want freedom like I'm also not wearing
pants
not wearing a waistband like I'm wearing
a nightgown and those I love the hatch
maternity bras though like if you are
looking for a tiny bit of support no
digging in right them they send me like
six of them I don't know what I would
have done without them
shout out
okay cool thanks for answering yeah okay
how about another personal question
how's your mucus plug
uh
I don't know I have become obsessed with
mucus plugs since I found out what they
were on your last pregnancy and I'm
always asking my pregnant friends I'm
like how's your mucus plug they're like
how do you know that
yeah but
okay I'm sure cool no they're like I'm
feeling like I'm gonna go early I'm like
well did your mucus blood but it's not a
waste so textbook no I know I know but
like I just want to impress people with
like the things that I know got it my
with Harry so many things were like so
textbook pregnancy like a movie it was
just like crazy I guess it was nice that
it was the first one and so many things
like went as they should because It
prepares you for what to expect because
now I like it
no that makes sense that it was like a
movie it makes sense that it was like a
movie because you gave birth to a movie
star oh totally
baby Harry
yeah so just come down to the wire
trying to stay comfortable
and do you want me to give you a foot
massage you want to come over later if
you can do a good one Zach's been
getting a little bit let me touch your
feet for sure
I don't know if you if your skills would
be like worth the touching Trust and
Believe
I got you also at the time you come over
is not really when I'm like craving one
okay when Zach is giving you foot rubs I
think about this all the time because
like I always make Ben rub my feet and
he's like he's good at it but like stops
after 10 seconds yeah I've been doing
this for two hours but like I imagine
like I I always think I'm I'm like you
know like when I am pregnant God willing
you will never stop like not for one
moment not to go to the bathroom like
you will rub my feet till your hands
bleed you think no okay so that's what I
was like last night Zach was giving me a
foot massage she was actually going well
and I wasn't like begging for him to
stop because he usually just does it so
bad that I'm like forget it right so
weaponized incompetence he was doing a
nice job and I was like okay more and it
was literally maybe five minutes total
and he was like oh like it it's you
think that when you get pregnant your
husband's Just Gonna Give You massages
all day every day but like they really
don't
and unless it's good like my one of my
irks is like being rubbed in the same
place over and over again yeah it like
hurts and just becomes tender and is
doing nothing yeah so unless it's good I
don't even want it
100 I feel that like completely I hate
when people like keep rubbing on the
same spot it's like it's like a sensory
thing yeah no it's really really irks me
but like when I go get a pedicure or
something I get my feet rubbed
um it's wonderful so it's not me
no a pedicure chair like massage even
for a few minutes is I think you know
the closest to Heaven I'll ever get yeah
so it's not me it's it's just him and
his skills and I think like just like we
have to take you know labor and birthing
classes men should have to take massage
classes when their wives get pregnant
I love that there's no reason that the
massage shouldn't be good you have big
strong hands
and also like it's a massage it's not
rocket science right figure it out right
watch a YouTube video yeah no I think
that that should be normalized
I love love love love
yeah but you know somebody should offer
like one of those places that does like
prenatal classes like there's like a
class for women on the breathing they
threw the men in the corner and teach
them how to massage so they actually in
those prenatal classes they do teach the
men how to massage through labor pains
like there are certain no not the same
but I'm not I don't like at that point
no offense your massages and helping me
I'm talking about the 10 months prior
yeah
so free idea
today's episode of the toast is brought
to you by BarkBox BarkBox is a monthly
themed box of original toys delicious
treats and Unleashed joy every box is
tailored to your dog's unique needs and
personality designed to make them happy
BarkBox is made by bark the dog obsessed
company with one goal to make dogs as
happy as they make us so I've been a
BarkBox member it was literally the
first thing I did when I knew I was
getting a dog and it's so fabulous
because I feel like to keep up with the
endless cycle of toys and treats and
things to keep them occupied it can cost
a lot of money and it's also just like a
lot of work to keep replacing them you
know they chew through a lot of the toys
BarkBox just shows up every month that
I'm never I have never once since I've
had the run out of toys or run out of
treats I always have them on hand and
they're themed really cute like with
certain holidays they do like really
really cute boxes so it's always fun
Theo literally knows when the box is
arriving he gets like crazy and he makes
me give him a treat and his new toy and
he's occupied for the entire afternoon
it's really fabulous
and play time isn't just for pups it's
also for the pup parents every Bark Box
is designed to bring dogs and humans
together opening your monthly BarkBox
becomes a special tradition for the
whole family it's also hard to beat the
value and convenience of the box every
month you're getting high quality dog
goodies delivered right to your door and
BarkBox is just making dogs happy which
really we have to be incredibly grateful
to them for that sign up now and BarkBox
will double your first box for free
that's twice the toys twice the treats
and the chews to start spoiling your dog
visit barkbox.com toast that's
b-a-r-k-b-o-x.com slash toast today's
episode is also brought to you by modern
fertility think back to sex ed for a
moment you probably learned all about
how to prevent pregnancy but how about
how to plan for it if you're a big fan
of planning ahead like we are scheduling
trips months in advance plotting out
your next big career move
um and you've never thought about
planning for kids definitely check out
modern fertility it's why it was created
it's an easy and affordable way to test
your fertility hormones at home with a
symbol finger prick you mail it into
with a prepaid label and you'll get your
personalized results within six business
days you'll get insight into your
hormone levels like your ovarian reserve
AKA if you have more or fewer eggs than
the average woman your age and you'll
also get other important factors that
can impact your fertility the results go
deep into what every hormone means and
you can also download the results to
review with your doctor for next steps
traditional hormone testing at a
fertility clinic can cost over six
hundred dollars the modern fertility
tests the same general set of hormones
for only 179 dollars and if you go to
modernfertility.com toast you can get
twenty dollars off your test plus you
can get reimbursed for the test through
your FSA or your HSA so if you want kids
today or maybe one day in the future
clinically sound information about your
body can help you make a decision that's
right for you so right now modern
fertility is offering our listeners 20
off the test when you go to
modernfertility.com toast that means
your test will cost just 159 dollars
which when you think about what it would
cost at a fertility clinic is literally
a fraction of the price so get that
twenty dollars off your fertility tests
when you go to modernfertility.com toast
that's
modernfertility.com
t-o-a-s-t modernfertility.com toast
can I ask you a question and like it
might be
um my like you know tired hangover
making me like self-conscious but like
you seem like annoyed with me
foreign
like I'm taking what you said okay I'm
reflecting on the last 17 minutes and
I'm trying to see what could make you
think that and if in that time I became
annoyed with you yeah like if you're
just you know like pregnant that's fine
but like if I did something like let me
know no I don't think that you did okay
I just feel like I'm like being annoying
and I'm just trying not to be but like I
don't know what I did to be annoying you
know no I I'm I'm or it's all in my head
I'm internalizing no maybe if I listen
back like maybe you're it's you're not
making it up I'm terminalizing what you
said though which is why it paused
because I'm not just gonna be like no no
the hesitation like definitely gave me
pause the hesitation was meant to
indicate that I took your question
seriously
I so appreciate that Sheldon
that was so something Sheldon would say
so no I don't believe you in conclusion
we're good yeah okay okay you know
you're just like kind of giving like
annoyed older sister energy like
thinks that I am but if I am I apologize
no
no no apologies necessary I know I've
had a hard morning I don't mean to add
to your burden no no no no no no no no I
was just making sure
yeah not us having a fight no I'm I'm
now I'm trying to think back to like
what I said are we in a fight shut up
okay now you're being now you're looking
for a fight and now we are no now you
are looking for a fight
yeah yeah I am you'll find one I'm sorry
oh yeah I just need to open the bedroom
door and I'm ready to unleash
oh true have you not Unleashed yet
no I was like as he was getting home I
was setting up so I um I was clipped so
what is it gonna look like
honestly I feel like there's real power
in this island treatment like I don't
wanna
I think I really need to be like
like seriously like no talking okay
that's one of my favorite modes amazing
it's a mighty powerful weapon it is but
you have to have patience you have to
have the stomach for it for them to even
I notice that you're ignoring them but
it's more humiliating than me like I'm
not talking to my husband and literally
he doesn't even know he has no idea
luckily for me I'm an extremely patient
person so it works for me but I could
see you being like I'm bored let's talk
yeah I'm bored we're fine yeah let's
move on
um
yeah I don't know if you know this book
I have been ignoring you and like that
was really not cool of me I'm sorry
literally
um should we dive in I feel like that's
what we're here to do it is what we're
here to do we have some really nice
stories to wrap up the week I feel like
all the stories this week have really
been piggybacking off of one another so
yes it's been update after update I
think today's episode will tie up a
number of loose ends
also we're going into you know night two
of eras LA and I want to say just like a
promise if a singular Kardashian because
we have I think six shows left there's a
ton of shows in L.A if you singular
Kardashian
goes to the arrow store just one of them
there will be an emergency podcast on
patreon I will probably sit down with
Margo or someone who cares and
I just don't worry okay because that's
what been my concern like the the timing
of your maternity leave is amazing like
August is such a slow month but it's La
hours and we've been talking about it
for so long so if anything happens last
night no one was there if anything
happens there will be an episode don't
worry what were the songs last night
stay still no yes stay no
I can see you waiting down a hall with
me and then it was either maroon or
Stacey no it's maroon is maroon they're
getting to be like not that well maroon
she had already played so it was a
repeater and I can see it was a new song
it's honestly my least favorite
um
Vault song yeah I just had like a stroke
um my least favorite vaults on so I'm
okay with these yeah no like I don't
know why everyone's treating La so
special I don't know why she did the
most shows there like if she had
announced six shows anywhere all six of
them would have sold out like La is not
special everybody there needs to calm
down and they're annoying me wow I'm
just jealous the surprise songs are kind
of losing their luster I don't know if
it's because this has gone on for so
long or because like she gave like a
song from a recent album and a vault
song like
and for people who are like passive fans
not even me because I think I'm a very
active fan compared to the average
American but the people who are passive
fans like they don't [__] know those
of all songs backwards and forwards yeah
I think like the amount of passive fans
at these shows is like less and less
either because passive fans are becoming
activated
well no that's the only reason sorry
okay okay
yeah um but for me any show where peace
isn't played is a win I think it's like
pretty obvious now it'll never be played
it's just like not a song that's even
it's not even an option so I don't even
I used to wait up for like every show I
don't even check especially with these
West Coast times girl I'm going to bed
yeah
I mean what is so even if you waited up
and checked then what would happen then
you still have to go to bed
it's an amazing point that you raise
yeah so you might as well find out in
the morning the end of my husband keeps
waking me up as early as he does I'll be
the first one to know on the East Coast
totally you could get a flight in time
for the next show literally
I'm all right so let's save in girl girl
let's get into the fast five stories
that you need to know today
great thank you Claudia our first story
is this the big first step to Meghan
markle's comeback Wait I'm obsessed
there's actually a lot going on with
Meghan Markle did you see her at her
42nd birthday party yeah looking like
the Snapchat glamor oh my God I'm
obsessed so today is her 42nd birthday
party and insiders are saying that she
is getting on Instagram with her
Instagram page ready to roll out after
quietly making uh getting ready to make
a comeback online so the handle at Megan
already has like a couple thousand
followers and people are speculating
that it is Megan's personal account that
will be forthcoming with content soon
and that is going to be like one way
that she comes back into the spotlight
no I'm like extremely here for it and I
actually think
um this isn't a bad idea I think you
know sharing your life on social media
is a great way to
like show who you are and I feel like so
much of if I feel like she definitely
feels misunderstood in a lot of ways and
a lot of the things that are written
about her so to be able to just like put
out your own narrative and your own
content like I kind of love this for her
and like this is a who she was before
she was a royal like her Blog the tig
she's very lifestyle I feel like it's
going to be very like Oprah Martha
Stewart Farm Vibes I'm here for it 100
and that outfit that birthday party I
never saw somebody look so beautiful in
my life and that wasn't even like a good
high quality Paparazzi photo yeah no she
did look wonderful celebrating her
birthday I agree that Instagram could be
a good Avenue for her to take a stab at
like becoming like a lifestyle
influencer I feel like one from what
we've seen of their lives like it's very
you know they have the chickens and she
could do the whole Martha Stewart thing
maybe a little Joanna Gaines sprinkled
on top like cooking home family mom
um and she should give that a shot as
her next like career path I think that
that might really work out for her I
completely agree I will definitely
follow if but this is all like a
conspiracy theory nobody knows for sure
if this random account that popped up
called at Megan is her I mean it's a
good guess it's a pretty good guess and
it would make sense as like her next
4A as her career the only thing that I
think that she will need to like be very
conscious of is like being actually
authentic and like the way that her
podcast came off so produced to people
like people don't like to see that stuff
on social media where it's like all you
know
high quality images like not iPhone
pictures all captions like it needs to
be
semi-real yeah no I think I think you
make a really good point especially as
it pertained to the podcast where there
are really no successful highly produced
podcasts like they're all just very raw
very real no time limit unless they are
like a storytelling podcast like fiction
yes sorry I'm talking about like a
hosted by people yeah four people
um Instagram like you can be very uh
produced if you want to and it's not the
worst thing in the world but if she
wants to utilize it in the way that I
think she does you're right it needs to
have you know a dash of authenticity
like it needs to kind of look like she
runs it herself even though she probably
doesn't and that's totally fine there
will be a Content calendar and a
schedule as there should be but they
need to focus on making it feel very
real because I feel like that's been the
criticism from some of her other
projects and that's also what works on
Instagram like relatability with a
little bit of aspiration you know it's
all it's a recipe and I think it could
be a recipe for success for her yeah I
think yesterday was a very good PR day
for Meghan Markle she looked stunning
everyone's excited about her Instagram
I'm excited about her Instagram
um I think this is good yeah so
hopefully she would start to post soon
if this is really her A source told page
six that she was set to like go back to
Instagram right before her podcast
launched but then she changed her mind
so it's just like sitting there now and
she had said in her interview with the
cut that she was going to come back to
Instagram and then she never did so it's
not so far-fetched no it's not
definitely not especially it's like her
passion with everyone watching Suits
like that's part of the of the
restreaming processes you get a bunch of
Instagram followers me and Ben sat down
last night and I'm like we're gonna
start a new show Suits and he was like
oh okay and then the first episode's an
hour and a half and it was already like
9 30 and we were just not wanting to
stay up that late but he's like I'm so
down just like not right now I keep
telling Zach like he should watch suits
because he watches like that I don't
know what kind of show that is called
but that's like what he watches he
watches like yeah designated Survivor
like all people in offices yeah in high
power jobs
and I'm like it's suits like you should
watch you should he he hasn't been
influenced yet but maybe he will be but
last night we actually were watching
quarterback
oh it's like a really cute not cute it's
a good concept for a show it follows
like three quarterbacks this season like
three real ones they're all oh that was
just Patrick Mahone no Patrick Mahomes
Kirk Cousins and Marcus Mariota and
they're all very different quarterbacks
like in different phases of their career
oh so you had told me
about it and I told Ben I'm like we
should watch it I thought it was like
such a nice thing for me to say he was
like no I want to watch Sean White's
documentary the snowboarder
um so we watched that it was good I like
saying Nina Dobrev Ben is like obsessed
he grew up in like the Billabong X Games
Ben used to [__] love the X Games
like so it's really his passion I
couldn't really care but I did I did
like a lot of the Olympic footage I
enjoyed it very cool what's crazy is I
was enjoying quarterback enough like you
know one eye on one eye I've seen with
Zach but Zach was the one who turned it
off because as I said and he agreed it
was too much football it was like we
were re-watching games that like if you
care about these games you've already
seen there was behind the scenes stuff
but like there was literally would be
like five minutes of like game content
and it's like we saw these games it was
last year
yeah no that's annoying and so Zach said
it was too much football
oh damn yeah but uh it was cute and it
seems like a pretty cool concept that
they like literally got to follow
Patrick my homes for a year and he won
the Super Bowl yeah that is cool but
Kirk Cousins seems like a really nice
guy
let me look him up I don't know what he
looks like is he cute he's really cute
he's very Kirk is such an underrated
name oh what a cutie and him and his
wife are and they have like kids are
very normal and apparently she dresses
him for all of his games and she just
like shops at like Sam's Club and Target
and like all of his shirts like go viral
because people are like I'm obsessed
with his wife his style isn't like great
but it's like her picking them out and
who was the other guy Marcus Mariota
he had an interesting Tory too it was
his Italian Mariota it was his first
season with the Falcons
um he's also like and also his wife and
Patrick mahomes's wife at the time of
filming are pregnant so there's just
like a lot going on in the life of a
quarterback which I think is the point
is incredibly hot yeah have I never
heard of this person I know I said to
Zach that's the only name that like
didn't ring a bell he said that wasn't
surprising but it's also because he like
has kind of bounced around a little this
was like a big first season for him and
I think based on like the you know
coming up this season stuff he might
have gotten like benched at one point
yeah I don't know like that's kind of
embarrassing when you have a Netflix
stock right so it was pretty cameras
down that they got that that is yeah I
won't be watching anymore but I enjoyed
what I could watch
so Megan might be on Instagram stay
tuned
are you staying tuned
yeah I'm waiting for you to say the next
story okay next story Beyonce has a very
interesting object on her rider for the
Renaissance World Tour that is Making
Waves Beyonce is bringing on her
Renaissance tour to every stop I like
little golf cart box full of her own
toilet seats
I'm sorry what's a golf cart box like
it's a box that has to be like put into
it like uh if I showed let me send you
this picture you'll is it like a toilet
she can use on a golf cart no no no I
think they put their own toilet seats
onto the toilets at the arena Stadium I
mean I do feel like
you know sanitizing them is probably
enough also there's not like that many
people who go to the personal bathroom
of the big dressing room in an arena but
I understand I understand unless it's
like a a Toto toilet seat and it's warm
oh I see this picture okay so she's
bringing her own toilet seats you know
what
I feel like
at a certain point like all the [__] on
someone's Rider like Beyonce probably
doesn't even know
I think she does I think this is
honestly I
goals like first I think it's a total
toilet seat because really like to bring
swap at one twist
a toilet can you just attach a Toto
toilet seat to a regular toilet maybe
Beyonce has a travel Toto maybe they've
made one so you're saying they are
uninstalling the toilet in her dress no
no just the part you put your ass on
no but I'm saying Toto like being a
heated seat and everything you needed to
connect it to a Toto toilet in order for
it to work I think that she has a travel
Toto
that doesn't need to be connected to a
Toto that right that you could put on
any old Bowl
let's see if they do warm and spray you
and wipe your ass
oh you're 100 right they do sell just
the seat with the bidet
it's 500 bucks
I think she has that on her tour and I
think she should it comes in cotton and
Sedona beige gorgeous
yeah I could see that it has a air dryer
a heated seat cleansing spray deodorizer
yeah I see that those are all things you
need on a tour
so true you got to keep that [__] tight
when you're you know entertaining
thousands yeah I think it's
um
very ingenious and more people should do
it assuming that's what the toilet seat
is but the lip the box is literally
labeled toilet seats so like they are
bright and it says Beyonce toilet seats
they're bringing their own toilet seats
if you had a rider what would be like
the craziest thing on it
nothing at the moment because I'm very
low maintenance but if I ever reach
World Tour status I'm sure I would have
built up to some really exciting
ass I probably have like a frozen yogurt
machine
and I need them to transport my personal
bed to every venue so I can lay in bed
until the minute I have to go on stage
yeah
just some initial thought starters I
actually do have a rider when I'm on
tour but it's very simple like snacks
tequila mirror
handheld fan you know nothing crazy
nothing crazy one day you'll get to
bring your own toilets yeah one of these
days
dream big today's episode is brought to
you by kiwico summer is the time to make
memories with your kids whether you're
staying at home or heading out on
adventures kiwico invites kids and kids
at heart to celebrate the season of
Discovery through Hands-On fun so kiwico
is a company that delivers monthly
science and art projects that turn
curiosity into creativity from creating
giant Bubbies bubbles to experimenting
with ice cream kids will learn in a
seriously fun and Hands-On way and
there's something for everyone so you
can discover subscription lines for kids
of all ages ranging from infants to
preschoolers all the way up to teens if
you are a parent or you spend any amount
of time with children you know that it
can be really hard to keep them you know
entertained and occupied and if they're
learning that's a huge bonus you know
without just throwing the TV on so
kiwico encourages kids to get outside
and explore and keep them off their
screens they have awesome projects from
the kiwico store like the bottle rocket
kit which helps turn the outdoors into a
playground of learning and fun they make
it easy to discover on the go so
everything you need comes in a crate
including the materials and easy to
follow instructions it's the perfect uh
travel boredom Buster for the entire
family as a parent we know it can be
hard to create and find creative ways to
keep your children busy and challenged
they do the legwork for you at kiwico so
you can spend quality time tackling the
projects together there's something for
kids of all ages and there's no
commitment so you can pause or cancel at
any time have an awesome summer with
kiwico get 50 off your first month plus
free shipping on any crate line with
code toast kiwico.com that's 50 off your
first month at
k-i-w-i-c-o.com the promo code is toast
spelled of course
t-o-a-s-t today's episode is brought to
you by Squarespace Squarespace the
all-in-one website platform for
entrepreneurs to stand out and succeed
online whether you're just starting out
or managing a growing brand Squarespace
makes it easy to create a beautiful
website engage with your audience and
sell anything from products to content
to time it's all in one place and it's
all on your terms now in this day and
age you gotta have a website whether
you're you know starting an e-commerce
business starting your own business
creating a side hustle a website is a
perfect place for people to be able to
contact you see all your previous work
and just get to know you but it can be
really daunting to create a website it
can be really hard
um and Squarespace is just that platform
they make it so easy they have amazing
features anyone can do it you can get
your website up and running in a matter
of you know minutes they have great
features so if you're looking to sell
merch you can do that if you're looking
to create an online store you can do
that they have flexible templates that
are really easy to use and are going to
make your website look super super
professional
um you can do email campaigns with
Squarespace you can you know show your
video collections you can do a point of
sale so if you want to start selling
stuff in real life you can use the
Square Reader on the Squarespace app you
can keep your orders your inventory and
your customer data in sick in sync with
your online store
so again today's episode is brought to
you by Squarespace and of course we do
have a code for you guys head to
squarespace.com for that free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com toast and you'll save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
a domain that's
squarespace.com toast to save 10 off
your first purchase of a website or a
domain today's episode is also brought
to you by stamps.com when every person
moment and penny counts in your business
you can't afford to take any of them for
granted and stamps.com they get it
because for the last 25 years they've
been helping businesses Like Yours save
time and money so you can focus on your
business knowingstance.com has all of
your postage needs covered with premium
discounts and great rates so with
stamps.com all you need is a computer
and a printer they even send you a free
scale so you'll have everything you need
to get started if you need a package
pickup you can easily schedule it
through your stamps.com dashboard and if
you sell products online stamps.com
seamlessly connects with every major
Marketplace and shopping cart the best
part is that they offer premium
discounts because running a business is
not cheap especially when it comes to
fulfilling orders for your customers
luckily stamps.com is a huge carrier
discounts they get up to 84 off USPS and
UPS rates plus stamps.com automatically
tells you your cheapest and fastest
shipping options they've been your
postage partner for the last 25 years
they've been an indispensable resource
for over a million businesses get access
to the USPS and UPS services that you
need right from your computer anytime
day or night there's no lines no traffic
and no waiting so set your business up
for Success when you get started with
stamps.com today sign up with the promo
code toast and you'll get a special
offer it includes a four week trial plus
free postage and a free digital scale
there's no long-term commitments or
contracts just go to stamps.com
s-t-a-m-p-s.com Click the microphone at
the top of the page and enter code toast
that's code toast thank you stamps.com
for sponsoring today's episode okay next
story is a little more toward news
because Taylor Swift has announced more
errors tour dates for the US and Canada
in Fall 2024. you guys this is so
exciting 10
turns out it's not the end of an era
Miami New Orleans Indian Toronto the
Eros tour is coming to you in 2024 with
Gracie Abrams
and she gave us dates so next fall
Taylor in Miami like I'll be there
so crazy because she started this tour
in like the spring of 20
oh 2023
I guess it's like not that crazy oh okay
she's just doing a lot it's just crazy
that she's like coming back after
everything that she's doing overseas so
crazy I was literally just about to sit
here and be like I can't believe this
tour has been like end up lasting three
years I don't know how to do any math no
it's three to four years in Claudia's
book but it's quite literally like 14
months yeah so far I I feel like she'll
wind up adding more U.S dates if she's
coming back and more parts of Canada
because Toronto is just one eastern city
right but I'm so glad that we have
confirmation for Florida because I will
get to go to the Irish tour which was
something that I made peace with yeah
that I couldn't go and I was totally
okay with that but this will be so fun
yeah it's gonna be a blood bath I'm
having you now to get tickets
yeah more so than the first time
it's just a different part of the
country that she didn't go to she did
Tampa actually so maybe it'll be like a
little less no it's still it's just it's
crazy no matter what yeah well we'll do
the cue if that doesn't work we'll
overpan StubHub yep but we're gonna go
we're gonna have a nice time I'm very
excited I'm looking forward to a clear
my fall 2024. yeah and then also what
was so exciting was Luke posted
yesterday to wrap up his US tour Luke
Combs and he said that's the end of the
U.S tour for now
not Luke leaving Easter eggs Luke told
me he's coming back to the U.S
you will definitely be able to see all
the concerts that you missed so you
should feel good about that like you're
fine and then you get to also have a
child which is fabulous so fabulous the
only one now I'm waiting on but I'm not
gonna get greedy because two out of
three like I is enough for me Diana I
didn't think I would get one Morgan
Wallen yeah yeah I don't know if that
show's ever going to be rescheduled no
he rescheduled a ton of shows for the
fall
oh he would have to add that life
whatever shows he didn't do because of
his loss of voice yeah I believe those
are in the fall but I'm hoping that he
adds more dates because those cities
were not like I mean I guess I could go
if I wanted to but that doesn't really
work for me so wait Jax what are your
surprise songs like what do you want for
tailored
no oh my gosh well I know for Luke
I'm more interested in Luke's surprise
songs because apparently all my favorite
songs don't get played at his show but
by the way you know that he does do a
surprise song
what was yours before
um the show they have this QR code it's
like scan it and vote he gives you three
options one of them is that Ed Sheeran
song Dive that he's like very famous for
covering one is
um
I don't remember
I think but what was your guys you guys
had like a sponsored song yeah that's it
T-Mobile like does and I believe it was
See Me Now from the album
got it where was it still it was still
that would be amazing surprise song yeah
I think it was I can't remember I'm like
my Amnesia okay what are your Taylor
songs okay I'm going I just looked at my
tailor like my liked songs on Spotify
search Taylor
um
I have some Midnight's favorites but
they're all like kind of sad I don't
know if that's a Vibe okay like snow on
the beach she doesn't play right she has
uh it's actually like one of the first I
like bigger than the whole Sky too but
it's just like not the vibe I don't
think she's played it I think that's
like actually too sad yeah agreed so I
shall keep going I want one of the
classics honestly okay like
I don't even know
like um let me go to her are you okay
her album um it's overwhelming it is and
I just like I don't
I a lot of my favorite songs like she
plays already like I'm not trying to
write oh right you know what I mean yeah
did she she plays the Archer
yes okay
I'll be okay I'll take what I get I'm
excited I just hope no bald songs
because I'm not activated
what about like all too well 10 minute
version that's a vault song No but
that's in the set list yeah yeah no
Vault songs has surprise songs what
about better man
yeah that would be cool
that's a vault song
oh I I don't think of it as of all the
time I think of it as like a a song She
Wrote a cover yeah exactly
you know it's gonna be so great I'm so
glad that you're gonna get to experience
the Magic Christmas tree farm that's
what I want oh my God when's the show
October
[__]
that would be such a good surprise that
song is literally low-key amazing
amazing
and dance under Sparkle lights
and all these like I love Evermore and
folklore but when I look at the titles
of the songs like I don't know what song
it is until I listen to it do you know
what I mean and I do but that's not what
it's like for you no no because I'm like
a scholar in Evermore and folklore
studies does she play Gold Rush
no that I would like yes that's a very
good song okay so Gold Rush and
Christmas tree farm
who are the openers for the U.S shows
Gracie Abrams
okay good because when Haim comes
she doesn't play Tis the damn season she
cancels that one and brings them out for
nobody no crime well it's good cause
I'll probably have to go to the bathroom
at some point
no yeah I went to the bathroom during
this is gonna be a very hot take okay
lover
what song Lover Lover okay it's like not
my favorite song but it's kind of early
in the show no I was drinking like I
really had to pee but you broke the meal
how many more times did you pee I peed
five times at the first show and but you
also you had a bathroom in your Suite No
oh sorry okay sorry so the first time
when I went in a suite I peed at 22 and
I only peed once and it was no regrets
then when me and Margo just bought
random tickets the night of for MetLife
night one we had uh seats right by a
bathroom when I say it was a three
second walk and it was like weirdly no
line I peed five times and I peed during
lover and then the other four times I
peed when she was talking in between
songs and I didn't miss anything wow
yeah I would definitely go pee for 22. I
Knew You Were Trouble
I don't think did she play I Knew You
Were Trouble
I don't think she does and what's the
other song from that from red that's so
all too well 10 minute version she does
oh we are never getting back together oh
taking the time yeah by the way that and
22 are like back to back I was in the
bathroom going to the bathroom
changing my tampon
it's giving red applying my lipstick
literally
getting a drink yep yeah
that's so funny but you have to time it
good because red All Too Well 10 minute
version like that is like what I'm most
excited to hear
totally it's it's really like a
religious experience yeah
so thank you Taylor for that very
exciting for me
our next story a little more World Tour
news sort of Doja cat teases Victoria's
Secret World Tour performance so welcome
to the boss [__] World Tour Doja cat
revealed she will headline the upcoming
Victoria's Secret World Tour the
lingerie Brands revamped fashion show in
a new interview with Harper's Bazaar
Thursday and she rocks some very racy
lingerie looks for the event
um the program will debut on Amazon
Prime in September on September 26th and
I guess Doja is the performer
so but they've rebranded like it's not
the Victoria's Secret Fashion Show bsfw
it's Victoria's Secret World Tour
are they actually going on a tour
no I don't know it's very confusing it's
very confusing
it's a part Fashion Show part
documentary but is there a tour
no I don't think so but
I have to imagine they changed the name
because like the association was
negative from like all the years that
they did the show even though I think
people still like fondly look back on it
like even it you know say what you want
about body image or whatever like it was
a fabulous night on television like it
was like a kind of like a cultural event
yeah it was and also it's like still
call Victoria's Secret whether you want
to call it Victoria Secret fashion show
or Victoria Secret World Tour like we're
not dumb we know what we're watching no
so true not Victoria's Secret I think
they were stupid so you might as well
just like capitalize on the brand Equity
that you do have instead confusing me
with a world tour
and I feel like one performer is not a
lot I think towards the end they were
doing like three like Taylor was there
with Fallout Boy like they had like a
bunch of collabs yeah they would do like
around three performers they were always
so good yeah though I do so I told you
of the moment Doja cat is really a
perfect choice for this me too but who
else would we cast if let's say they did
three
then you have to like switch it up
because she kind of has like the pop
girly covered yeah honestly I feel like
Olivia Rodrigo
because also she's like promoting
something why'd you make a face and
you're not a really weird Rodrigo fan
I don't think so
I think maybe like I like her music I
think she's so talented
but I I don't know something I don't
like
okay not about her she seems lovely and
she's so talented but just like
I don't know I feel like she's been
doing some stuff that I'm just
meh are you speaking in defense of
Sabrina Carpenter maybe maybe that's
where it all starts for me that's
interesting because you're like a woman
who defends other women yeah and all
this stuff with Taylor like is so sus
it's so weird and there's definitely
beef
yeah
and it's just weird I agree okay
um all right so we're not casting her
then I guess we have to throw like a man
in it I could see like something now
like the Jonas Brothers would do 100 it
will be the Jonas Brothers 100
the Jonas brothers are getting like such
a unique sort of like career angle where
they're now just giving like you know
going to the opening of an envelope very
commercial like very yeah
like just selling every piece of their
business yeah but like I respect it and
at least they're still putting out good
music no it's true at the end of the day
like the Jonas Brothers do not put out
bad music it's just like Bob after Bob
they always work with Ryan Tedder like
they know what's good so you know what
you want to make tick tocks and you know
promote literally everything yeah like
do a Waze collab and perform at
Victoria's Secret yeah yeah
like they're selling like their voices
their speaking voice their singing voice
they're like everyone they are for sale
he's got Villa one but I also feel like
a children's book but I feel like that's
exactly why they got back together was
like expecting to make money so go ahead
and make money they're all husbands and
fathers and like it's a business they
also have a Popcorn Company yeah no
they're for sale
yeah and you know what nobody
understands that better than me because
one thing about me is like I can be
bought and apparently took in the Jonas
Brothers yeah for sure okay wait let and
then now let's think of our third and
final Act oh so it's Jonas Brothers Dojo
cat we need maybe like something like
more rock honestly like it'd be pretty
cool if it was like post Malone or
something oh yeah no I know I can see it
being like Travis Barker he kind of is
always popping up to that stuff yeah but
Travis Barker doesn't sing he's like a
feature blink 182.
oh okay cool yeah but do they have to
play new music or can they play like old
stuff I think they could play old stuff
okay I like that that's like a kind of
sickening lineup that we did yeah
actually you know who I could see
actually doing it right now Kelsey
ballerini 100
that's a guitar
or Kelly Clarkson
I [__] wish and I want that [__] in
lingerie
I love that [__] I love Kelly yeah and
she'll be like
like I love that
are you ready for our fifth and final
story I am like slurring my words I'm
really not okay I'm like having a stroke
but did you feel better good good our
fifth and final Story the microphone
that cardi B threw at a fan during the
Vegas show is being auctioned for
charity so the mic's good the microphone
that she held out her friend during her
show at Dre's Beach Club in Las Vegas is
being auctioned for charity on eBay
Scott Fisher whose company provided
audio support for the show as well as
for a lot of nightclubs in Vegas listed
the mic Tuesday morning and as of
Thursday afternoon the bid was at more
than 99 000 in the description he
claimed we provide more than one
microphone for this particular show and
verified with the in-house crew which
one was specifically used by cardi for
the show
got it um
I first thought it was like the person
who found it on the floor and like was
kicked out of the menu or whatever
um auctioning it off for profit but the
fact that it's like really legit that it
came from the production guys and that
they're what charity
the Wounded Warrior Project which is um
dedicated to helping veterans and
service members and the Friendship
Circle Las Vegas which supports people
with special needs
oh my God I used to volunteer with
Friendship Circle New York I love this
circle honestly wait at first I was
ready to be like oh my God everyone
tries to make a moment of everything but
yeah you know what this is all to the
good
yeah no it's nice um I don't know like
who the [__] is paying 100 Grand like
who who has a hundred grand I have no
idea
I feel like it's like people like
internet trolls kind of like bidding but
like you have to put down a credit card
you can't just like bid yeah no I don't
think they're expecting because it's on
eBay like you will get charged if you
win right
it could be like someone parties with
his fans
yeah
I want to find the listing just like to
see what's what's going on I mean people
are nutty people spent like how much on
that banana peel at Art Basel that's
true at least you got a microphone for
this with a little bit of
a funny story behind it Jackie um do you
know the brand of the microphone
sure
it is a her microphone oh my god well
that's worth its weight in gold
so there's 122 people who have bid on it
it's currently at a hundred thousand he
has lots of pictures of him with the
microphone
oh my God this is the funniest thing
ever
this is the sure microphone shown in the
viral videos carded through it a person
there are literally tons of links to
videos all over the Internet you can see
in the videos the white tape across the
bottom my name is Scott I'm the owner of
the wave it is an audio company we
provide yada yada
I was encouraged to sell this mic but
decided I would try to do something some
good 100 of the profit from the sale of
this Mike will be will be split evenly
among two Charities the first is a local
Las Vegas Las Vegas charity called
Friendship Circle Las Vegas the
Friendship Circle is an organization
that teens and young adults uh volunteer
helping children teens and other young
adults with special needs and the second
is Wounded Warrior Project
beautiful but there's like okay then he
like posted an update this very well may
fall upon deaf ears to any bitters but
this is an actual serious auction and
the money is going to a good cause if
you don't plan on paying for the item
please don't bid if you want a piece of
Hip-Hop Hip-Hop infamy and what has now
become a national and worldwide news
then please bid whatever you are willing
to spend thanks yeah I guess like you
could put your credit card in but could
get declined right damn oh and then it
gave another update uh yesterday that a
company called LM cases is going to
donate a case for the microphone the
case that they are building is going to
be more of a display type and we'll have
a lexin cover so the winner can display
the mic in their office or wherever they
decide to keep the mic thanks to Billy
at LM cases for this
yes so I don't know what anyone would
care enough to do with this microphone
and to spend that much money on it
really but I like where their heads at
no this was like a really sweet thought
did you see cardi B's tweet yesterday
about the Orthodox Jews I did
she's kind of losing her marbles okay
you know what I had totally forgotten
about it until this very moment shout
out I saw it on Liz height story
um what the [__] she was basically
saying like come for me I don't care
because I have Jewish lawyers yeah but
what she posted on Twitter was a picture
of two Orthodox Jews who are probably
definitely not her lawyers no no they're
like civilians in the streets yeah she
like Google image Orthodox shoes and
then she just wrote caption remember dot
dot because I think the charges like or
whatever law legal thing that was
happening due to her throwing the
microphone has been dropped so I think
that was her saying like because of my
Jewish lawyers
and I'm just like really not into it
like the the incessant thing in
Celebrity culture like throwing Jews
under the bus like I'm really over it
and I need everyone to shut the [__] up
and eat my [__] ass like for real my
big hairy Jewish ass that's not a lawyer
like seriously stop it's really starting
to piss me off no it was a very
icky like I'm I'm All About The jokes
but that wasn't funny no it wasn't funny
it was confusing and when you just like
post a picture of two Orthodox juice
without context it's like
you're inviting like all sorts of like
hate speech yeah no I'm not into it I
feel like I'm always defending cardi but
like she's actually pissing me off now
with the microphone thing and now this
like it's because I just read the
Nightingale like sometimes I'm like okay
to laugh stuff off and when something is
funny like I can acknowledge it it's
funny but like it wasn't funny you're
annoying and um and I hate you yeah no
it wasn't funny and it wasn't a joke
it wasn't a joke I don't know what the
point was yeah I don't know what it was
yeah I wasn't good she's rubbing me the
wrong way
yeah yeah first you know the assault
yeah where you know now that I've had
enough time like she was wrong you know
at first I was really on her side and
now I'm like um actually you were wrong
she should buy the microphone if no one
can actually pay for it
oh my God I love that idea and give the
money to charity
and then we can wrap up this whole
incident with a nice big with a nice bow
I love that Jacks except for the Tweet
the Tweet is the outline yeah the Tweet
remains question mark yeah
five now I'm in a bad mood thanks cardi
I forgot about that sorry but you have
some time off now good mood
oh yeah okay so
let's talk okay
we're gonna miss you so much
I'm gonna miss you well I mean I'm gonna
see you like every minute of every day
yeah I'm actually coming over after the
podcast can't wait to see you
of course September 5th is when we
return guys and we will be back with a
hybrid Jackie will probably be joining
us at first once a week
um and
it just won't be the same without you
Jax
yeah but you know what I'm excited to
see what you do with the show and make
it your own with all the guest co-hosts
I'll be watching because the toast is a
perfect you know new mama companion so
I'm excited to be a toaster I'm excited
to have updates for everyone and to
embark on this next chapter and I just
want to thank everyone who has been so
supportive of everything just like all
the nice comments messages I've gotten
over the last four or five months like
you guys are seriously the best like we
have the best community we have the
nicest fans and I love you all thank you
for all of the words of encouragement
and prayers it did not go unnoticed I
think I speak forever and when we say we
wish you an easy Speedy healthy fabulous
delivery
um we will all be thinking about you we
will be praying for you I will be right
next to you you want me in the delivery
room by the way we haven't even spoken I
think that these days you are allowed to
people but no please please
[Applause]
about a mucus plug and you're like no I
Would by the way I would take it so
seriously I would be so [__] quiet I
would just be like a butler to you like
whatever you need
and then I'll be up top and like think
about it like it would be so amazing
like sisterly connection we would be
even closer than possible and then think
about all the content we could do the
con and no we're not doing any [__]
content no afterwards afterwards I
wouldn't take a single photo in the room
I swear okay two things one I'll talk to
Zach and two it will depend what time of
day it is you know because if it's yeah
oh if it's a million icon last time I
gave birth in the middle of the well by
the morning but I was in labor in the
middle of the night like you were
sleeping
I was yeah you were at a show I was I
was I was you said you think you'd go to
Boston well I don't have any plans for
tour I'm here and just keep in mind talk
to Zach about it and I just know I would
be on my absolute best behavior
I would be just seriously like a courier
you need something I'll go get it
yeah
we would giggle you know what I not even
for any of reasons that like I couldn't
handle you being there but I don't know
if you could handle it and if you're
already like not looking forward to the
joys of pregnancy and childbirth like I
think it would be scarring to see me in
like pain
because you know I I like if I'm
complaining about the degree of pain
like what it would mean for you but
don't you think it would be so beautiful
that I would be like I'd get pregnant
that night maybe you'd inspire me Jax it
maybe but I do know you and I know that
here's the thing here's the thing think
about it I don't want an answer right
now just think about it I will think
about it I will
talk to Zach no brush but just tell me
what time to be there okay I mean if I
knew that would be great but I don't
yeah of course of course all right you
guys for the final time for a month so
dramatic we're all gonna be fine we'll
see you in a month and literally go
enjoy the rest of your summer listen to
good guys listen to mood with Lauren
Elizabeth drink awesome Shooters listen
to awesome Music Fall in Love
and we'll see you soak up each other's
awesomeness soak up each other's
awesomeness and we'll see you at the end
of summer
thank you guys so much for listening to
the testimony Morning Show where we
deliver the faster stories you need to
know everybody the friend on YouTube so
for watching us on YouTube please don't
forget to subscribe give this video a
thumbs up also available podcast
anywhere podcasting thumbs up Spotify to
institution Republic
Services
have a great summer
make sure you're following us on
Instagram updates on you know what's
going on with me updates on Jacks like
follow us on Instagram at Jackie ashray
at girl with no job and at the toast and
make sure you are a patron because if
you really miss us that's where we'll be
if you sign up today you will have
content to last you you could literally
listen to an episode every time no like
you could put it on and never turn it
off and by the time you turned it off
like we would be back in studio yeah
there's like 300 episodes
um but if you're already a patron one
thank you and two that's where you can
hear from us this month we have some fun
episodes planned some fun episodes
already in the can to get you through
those Last Licks of Summer
love ya bye love you bye